boolay cab show special guests in here
Mount Westmore yay Cube sure
three quarter we're missing Snoop Dogg
Mr Snoopy Dog somewhere
Snoopy you were Mr Snoopy Snoop uh hey
well look I'm so glad that this album is
actually here because I you know it felt
like one of these like methodical albums
that we always hear about and then it
never ends up coming out yeah how hard
was it to get everybody to like you know
this one coming out this ain't none of
that this is this is for real for real
for real for real I was hoping it wasn't
like detox 2.0 thing man like we we had
many opportunities to pull the trigger
but it was like should we right and we
discussed it as like you know for
intelligent Minds you know powwowing and
we like what's that date that day could
have been October 2020 he's gonna drop
that we could have dropped all of last
year anytime earlier this year and we
just we just felt like let's do some
things like get all the merch together
get all the Ducks and roll get you know
and we did an nft play foreign
which um
um you know once we put it out on the
nft
um we had to wait a certain amount of
time before we can actually put a
different record out on the street this
is a different record than than the nft
uh some of the songs are the same but a
few most of these are new how how
lucrative is the nft play is that I mean
because a lot of artists are going that
direction I mean Snoop pulled doggy
style and all the death row stuff off of
dsps like
you know it's a thing where it was great
for us
um because we you know got a great deal
uh but you know the nft market the whole
crypto Market has been like going
backwards ever since like Mother's Day
so yeah it's been bad so it just was not
great timing for the group but it was
lucrative for the group so you know in a
lot of ways it worked in a lot of ways
if we did it when it was a bull market
instead of a bear market then it would
have did a lot better right you know uh
we always plan to make sure it hit the
street though uh you know that was uh
that was a you know one of our demands
that yeah we can do this nft play but at
some point this music gotta hit all
platforms you know CDs we making albums
we doing everything you can do
um to get this to the streets and
December 9th is the date yeah Friday
um I'm curious man because you guys all
have very uh unique Journeys obviously
both y'all were on Jive for a very long
time
um Cube you've been a major label artist
you've gone independent nowadays it
feels like the transparency of record
deals is higher people are talking about
it more in terms of like some of these
shitty deals that are getting offered
Meek Mill's talked about it a lot
recently
um what is your guys's like uh thoughts
on just like where the game is and like
artists becoming a lot more self-aware
on some of the deals they're signing
because I'm assuming like everybody's
probably signed a deal that they're not
the craziest about you know what I mean
and you guys have seen all sides of the
game whether it's doing the independent
[ __ ] doing the major label [ __ ]
well you know um my Westmore we doing it
like one at a time so uh we're not
really like uh getting buried up under
contracts or anything like anything like
that we we definitely um the group is
definitely grossed quite a bit of money
before any anything ever drives well the
tour's been going you guys yeah doing a
lot of tour dates show shows we did
really good on merch we did um really
good with uh you know some early stuff
we did like we appeared at the trailer
event when Jake I remember that yeah
that was a big payday and you know we
just kind of is that the same fight um
Nate Robinson took the uh no no it was
the one after right it was one before he
took the he took the L before that fight
I believe I can't remember but it was it
was yeah and I remember that was though
it was in Atlanta but you guys have been
building this for I mean big subwoofer
has been out over a year so yeah so it's
like a it's like a business play man
everything is thought out in advance
when we gonna drop the album when's the
next album coming what a division was
going to do like you know what's the
next money place it's more like a
business and I think that um I think
that this market right now for a young
artists they don't have to just go sign
to a major label and get buried or do a
360 deal they could really like go do
deals with different platforms and
different type of spaces where the music
could live it's so much it's so many
different places that a song or an album
a project can go right now so you know
you gotta just Factor all that in and
not just do that old conventional one
street you know like get into the
physical you can't do that like you got
to do a lot of stuff so I think um it's
a good time to like uh you know we got
good leverage on this being instead of
snooping Cube before he is short and we
oh geez and we solid we don't have we
didn't have to go in there and they're
like well I'll give you a deal but you
got to sign on for like seven albums
like we it went out with us what would
you Cube what would you uh advise like a
younger artist who's maybe got like a
like a solid local Buzz they get you
would you would you
you know give them advice to explore the
major label route or or try to stay as
independent as long as possible
stay as independent as long as possible
as long as you can
you know when you do your music without
a record label you own a hundred percent
of it
and once you sign with a record label
you you basically giving them
a percentage of your work so if you have
the
the
discipline
and the resources
to be an independent artist then you
should do it a lot of guys are and I let
40 speak on it but a lot of guys are
um
you know they signed 360 deals and
that's like one of the worst deals ever
invented in man so uh some of them start
you know you get real
educated on deals once you sign a bad
one because you realize why why the
money is not making it to me yeah well I
haven't gotten any royalty checks it's
almost like the last check you ever see
is the advance so they they start to you
know nothing will teach you more
about the music business than signing a
bad deal and you
figuring out why it's bad right and then
you become an expert and uh I'll kick it
over to 40 to you know give a few
comments on it well nowadays you know
um the new uh era the new generation has
it pretty damn good and I'm happy for
them and they smart a lot of these
youngsters are smart they don't have to
sign with a major a major give you a
good if you like I can't I can't really
put a
age group on I'm not talking to the mic
I can't put an age on it but just say
you just say you 18 or 19 and you signed
a deal for three years and that label
blow you up
it might be it might be good for you it
might be like they put they put the
whole house behind you that might be
cool right because that's what you need
because you know how to the the funding
for it
um the financials for you don't have you
don't have it so you you know you let
you let them you know do what they need
to do with you
um be smarter and make sure that um
you know you negotiate your Masters and
all that stuff you know how quick you
get them back and whatnot you know what
I'm saying but
that can be a that could be an advantage
for you
um if you're really young
you know me and because because then
once you get off that label then you got
the visual kids of the world and just
distribution deals you know 90 10 and
you know what I'm saying those tires the
foundations yeah that kind of stuff you
know and that way you can control your
own destiny and you're getting all the
gouda you understand me um keep your
bastards right you keep your Masters
careful yeah because it could go the
other way too some people sign you and
they don't do [ __ ] yeah you go out there
and do all the work and they get paid
you care about yourself right and now
they then they come out the world right
and won't want they cut and you feel
like man y'all didn't do nothing but so
you got to just be careful you got to
really know who you getting in business
with and and not just be happy to be
signed yeah but understand that this is
a business a lot of Minds a lot of land
mines in the major industry in the major
label industry with uh
come in that door with those smiles and
those meetings and they bring out the
whole staff and it's like catering and
they love you and they sell it yeah and
the check is big and you happy you're
celebrating and the product comes out
and it does whatever but somewhere you
know when I say landmines you can't
really get mad at the right person right
you call up there yelling and screaming
they're gonna Shuffle you you go up
there acting an ass they're gonna
Shuffle you you sit there and your next
single come out on your second album and
it's Stellar they gonna Shuffle and it's
like you're still a really good artist
and you get a lot of really good artists
lost in that major label sauce so if you
go there know what you're doing stay
independent you in charge of it you stay
in you stay independent you know that's
nothing that's an advantage I had over
many people that started off on major
labels I was independent for many moons
I was Independence six years before I
even you know I didn't sign my major
distribution deal into 20 into 1994 with
Jive I I came in the game in 1988
independent so it was six years I had to
you know to I went to college to learn
when I say college I'm talking about
just music industry College you know
unwillingly you know what it says I just
went because I had to learn I was in it
by force not by choice so then when I
signed my distribution deal was great
because I I already had the demand you
know understand I knew what I wanted and
it was great so I'm independent still
right now
um I control my own destiny but my whole
thing is is this nowadays you could do
what the majors do as a as an
independent Young artist all you gotta
do is hire Indies and you can hire Indie
radio people yep you know it's all kind
of stuff you can do and it's really up
to you you can you can promote yourself
social media is there content all that
work your content on the social media is
the biggest platform you're director
consumer now exactly you needed a deal
to get into the record store now you're
locked in you don't have to press up
hard CDs and all that stuff you just you
could we can go in there right right now
make a song right now today right now
put the beat up make a slap had it [ __ ]
on iTunes in 24 hours so you guys are
obviously done uh joint project together
Cube you're part of I mean we're talking
about groups I mean West Side connection
NWA West Side connection to me was like
the first like super group I mean NWA
start y'all started together so I don't
consider like y'all pulling together but
Westside Connection was
a super group for real
um what is for you being a part of of
these group situations or these group
albums that are historical what is the
process
like now with Mount Westmore how
different is it I mean I've been with
groups but nobody's been as big as the
group I'm in now of course
you know these guys
are Platinum selling artists that's been
in the game over 30 years some 35
um
and they're Superstars and so you know
with NWA we were all starting together
nobody was a superstar
um Mount Westmore I mean I mean West
Side Connection West Side connection we
were all kind of in the same click and
it all made sense
here uh these are guys that
uh we're friends and it started with a
friendship and respect and 30 years of
admiring each other
into getting a group with those guys
like I feel like um
I can rely on them
you know more than than I even relied in
NWA you know it was a lot of you know
dreads did the [ __ ] now but right back
then it was an arguing you know he was
we was trying to get it right we've seen
the movie yeah so so uh you know it's uh
it's been great to just relax and not
have to you know spearhead everything
and be the the front thinker or the the
one coming up with all the ideas or this
or that you know I'm not saying that I
had to deal with those other groups but
I trust these guys more than I trusted
the other guys because we were kind of
in the trenches together except for
maybe Dub C who's obviously still comes
out on stage
you know we we grew up in the same
neighborhood we grew up rapping against
each other we grew up playing football
against each other the best [ __ ] Walker
of all time yeah you know uh dub is is
amazing
um you know but you know
he
he you know he's a he's an artist that
I'm friends with from from childhood
these are artists that I grew up buying
their records you know dub I help them
put together some of his records so it's
a difference uh I'm a fan of these guys
and uh I wasn't necessarily
just a fan of those guys I was friends
and I like what they do so it's
different and it's easier to be with
superstars than than just guys that you
just put a group together with what up
y'all we gotta stop the interview real
quick tell you about our partners at
mybookie man look it's so much to gamble
on right now we got World Cup soccer we
got bowl games coming up NBA basketball
uh of course NFL man we're getting into
the playoffs in a few weeks well in like
six weeks or something like that uh with
that being said let's win some money all
right go to my bookie right now sign up
with that promo code bootleg and they
will match your deposit up to a thousand
dollars that's free money to gamble with
that's free money what are we talking
about my bookie uh let's talk about the
props you could bet on all kinds of
player props NBA points uh well Giannis
win MVP you can do Futures on the awards
season for the NBA uh so much going on
you could also still bet on the NFL
mvprs as well there's just so much ways
to get get money on my bookie but what's
most important is that they're giving
you free money you sign up at my bookie
right now you use the promo code bootleg
and they won't match your first deposit
up to a thousand dollars that's right
free money what are we doing head over
there put in some bets and let's try to
win some [ __ ] money together all
right my bookie use the promo code
bootleg let's get back to the interview
can you guys speak to like there's
always like a on
told like rivalry between Northern
California and Southern California and
I'm not hearing about that I never heard
of one ever in my life you've been ever
like out of my 35 years in hip-hop music
putting music on the Shelf I have never
now if you want to talk about BR before
that before rap for our streets I don't
think it was a rival it was just the
game it's the streets you know what I
mean that's a little Funk going on in
prisons
never been in hip-hop not hip-hop it's
always been supportive
think uh I think we admire each other
for what we don't do you know uh
the energy the the flavor
um that that Northern California Bay
Area artists bring is something
different new fresh I'm always looking
forward to seeing what it is and it's
different than the Southern California
flavor and um and I think vice versa you
know
um they hear stuff from from down here
that they like oh damn they aren't they
on a whole new page you know we we saw
similar but we we different it's like
cousins you know
y'all blood related but your household
is a little different than your cousin's
household I do feel like the bay is like
the I mean the most underratedly
influential region in all of rap if you
just think of Life
sonically slaying I mean you know I
think of like a guy's like the pack how
they influence the whole generation like
what 10 or 12 years ago like obviously
40 short you guys are you know on the
mount Westmore for sure
um
obviously the the record with pilo on it
very Bay Area uh I feel like I'm like
who's kind of picking the Beats who's
kind of helped a r in it and like would
you guys say it is like a
which region sonically is winning the
Bayer LA on the album we had to have a
balance it had to come from different
ways so you listened to if you heard the
album listen to the song have a nice day
uh [ __ ] You song it's definitely that's
definitely like Dr Dre influence
produced by Fred Reckless shout out to
Frederick uh lace you up definitely like
SoCal all day activated nice you know
it's it's on there and then you know you
got songs that are on the extreme other
spectrum of like uh free game and and
yeah basically I mean the two big
records of strip baby shout out to
pillow that's my bro but at the same
time if you leave the state of
California we're here if you leave here
they their ears just here West Coast
they're sure you don't hear that little
distinct you're right that a Bay Area
person La person with here in the song
and I think that uh the West Coast when
you get us all in the same room
we stand up together we always have you
you put uh Warren G and DJ Quick in the
room that we all we West Coast we
California boys we like we ride together
like for us it's not on basketball
obviously Sports and stuff you know you
gotta you gotta have it we're all riding
with the big three but when it comes to
like you know the professional teams
yeah but we definitely uh feed off each
other off the bay in the bay we got a
lot of Dr dreisms in Bay Area Music we
got a lot from Trey you know what I'm
saying uh recently I think uh you know
producers like uh like like mustard he
kind of like you know grabbed a little
bit of that bay energy and in a certain
way of course we don't got a gang or
lingo from the bay yeah but yeah you
know for sure so it's like it's just we
we are one but like he said we like
cousins and there is no Feud don't I
have not seen the feud or the
competition right who could come with
the hottest records we really and our
young rappers when you get the the
g-eazy's and all of them come out they
hanging out with the Kendricks they know
it ain't no
have you guys had the bipin talk with
snooping Cube about when you guys go do
promo in the bay like don't leave
nothing in the car they know it they
already know because they besides us
Cube and Snoop they got Bay Area fam too
we all locked in we all yeah that's
another thing yeah there's no sense the
warranty got real blood cousins
in Oakland yeah
I I was born I got cousins in Inglewood
like I got cousins all over the place I
was born on Sunset Boulevard man that's
crazy I got a whole million first
cousins in La not only are you guys
obviously historical artists great
discographies uh but you guys are all
Moguls within your own right and like I
mean some of the biggest Moguls in music
Snoop Dogg is killing the crypto space
he's just killing everything a bunch of
movies too yeah he on his movies so
speaking of movies Cube Vision speaking
locked in all of the liquor we're
drinking speaking of the big three the
Goon with the spoon Ice Cream come on
man uh what is you guys are you guys
like passing ideas around in terms of
just like business opportunities and
[ __ ] because I do feel like
you know there's there's this it's kind
of a very unicorn situation and not only
have historical artists but historical
businessmen in a group together without
a doubt you know we uh we started you
know not just a group we got a mount
Westmore LLC so it's a business and you
know we funnel great ideas into the
business you know when it's when it's
right we let everybody know this is
something that we should all attack that
as a group
and do it
um but I know I know we all involved in
investment groups uh I get the hint hint
we should start to mount Westmore
Investment Group yeah
let's do it take some my Westmore
profits and put them in some businesses
yeah yeah real talk any uh new uh stuff
coming from u40 I feel like every other
month there's like a new product I can
eat or drink so since the pandemic I
recorded over 70 songs since the since
I'm talking about since we finished the
mount Westmore album
because the grit don't quit but anyway
yeah I got a rule of thumb coming that's
that's my there's two albums oh rule of
thumb and I can I talked to Cuban I'm a
team player I don't know if it's
possible for you to not drop a double
album I know every time it's a double
album It's a triple album It's
I think he put an EP out during the
pandemic and I was surprised that you
had an EP and not like a full project
right right yeah no no EPS no more I did
EPS when I was young and I dropped one I
dropped one that I felt I needed to put
out because it was on my heart it was my
real assignment before they were saying
he understood the assignment
it was really my assignment to drop it
it was me as a little two-year-old kid
three-year-old kid
um standing standing in front of a
garbage can it was an EP but it was it
got some great songs on there and it was
a rule of thumbs next rule of thumb is
next rule of thumb two two albums and I
don't know if I'm gonna drop them
exactly at the same time or a week apart
but slaps
um I got a couple more
um uh features I need I need one I
already told Mount Westmore I'm taking
over this one song that I wanted and
they they agreed that I can have it and
so I'm slapping that on there and then
um I mean the slaps I got features I got
and I'm on there holding my own so you
always have the features unlocked and
you always tapped in with the younger
generation always tapped in with the
younger generation you know and I ain't
no slacking in my Mac and my link was up
to par I'm not trying to be young I
ain't trying to be on I'm just trying to
have a happy medium well I'm right there
and I'm gassing and I'm ahead of my time
you know what I'm saying I'm gonna ask
y'all because you guys all have classic
bodies of work solo uh Cube what is if
you had to what is your
your magnum opus of your discography
what's your favorite
album in your discography who do you
think is the best obviously America's
Most Wanted got five mics in the swords
you got the Predator you got lethal
injection I mean I would say death
certificate that's probably the one
because it's
the most dynamic
um
you know I think that's a great record
uh Predators a pretty good record laugh
now cry later is a good one but death
certificate is probably the cream of the
crop what about for you short
album best album
probably the best two short album is
probably getting it album number 10.
that's my favorite that's the that's the
um
we got orange cover I was on my man I
had that [ __ ] when I was a kid
production team that had been working
together for like five albums shorty B
and Banks Peewee myself we were the core
of like a production team that made a
lot of music it was a cohesive sound it
was and
uh before that my top seller was life is
too short that's like Classics that's
like that's the only double Platinum I
had but me when I listen to the music
and the production it's definitely
getting it that's the I was gonna ask
you because you also like over the years
short like
because you you guys have all been in
this [ __ ] since the 80s right but like
it's crazy when you listen to life is
too short and I can't imagine like
the [ __ ] you were saying on some of them
records well I used to have a technique
where um I kind of still do it but I had
a technique where before I would like
write songs I would just write down the
craziest stuff I could think of and just
like you know I guess it would be like
the shock value like a song like cuss
words had to be like at the time like
what the [ __ ] or [ __ ] Betty had to be
like people were like what is going on
it sounds like really long and there's
like a lot of rapping in like there's no
hook on the yeah the hook don't come for
like 48 bars you said [ __ ] he's a
true story yeah I killed her oh that's
terrible she choked on the Spiderman
died but it was like so far back before
social media and all that stuff it
didn't really get out there like that
are you saying the statute of
limitations has passed I mean it didn't
it doesn't exist there's no victim
there's no case to it there's you have
to go do some
some super forensics amount 40. what's
your best album
because you got a couple you could go
with there's a couple errors we could go
with yeah can I say can I go by the
errors yeah of course in the 90s it was
um
okay all right pick one is it in a major
way
your favorite You album come on man
that's easy no it ain't no it's not I
got two favorites say it then keep
saying two favorites I got like okay
come on man I'm you dealing with a dude
that got more top 200 billboard
the album entries in the history of
hip-hop listen listen listen listen
use your ears and listen let me ask her
foreign
his favorite E40 album is all the E40
albums give me one give me one
let me tell you one
you want me I'm gonna tell you something
it ain't it give me two of them I'm
gonna give you two okay give me two in a
major way okay
and tell him in a surprise oh devil
album oh yes sir them the sickest albums
I ever did and and uh and don't knock it
not not excluding get a report card in
the two in the 2000s what's your
favorite that was like in a major way I
mean my favorite favorite artwork you
got some legendary art favorite artwork
was one in a major way artwork when I
was in I was you know cooking Yola in
the Gumbo Pot you know making soup
between all of us and Snoop Doggy
oh for sure artwork has been amazing nah
for sure just forget about the music and
just the album covers are like legendary
a hundred percent yo what UPS bootleg
Kev gotta interrupt the interview shout
out to our good friends at Blue chew it
is cuffing season it's getting cold as a
[ __ ] outside right now and uh you could
definitely use a little extra um fellas
all right Bluetooth will have your dick
harder than goddamn trigonometry all
right so if if you really really you
know trying to get your dick game right
trying to make sure you prefer
performance is at an all-time high go to
Bluetooth right now bluetooth.com use
the promo code bootleg they're going to
give you a month supply for free that's
right a whole month for free
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free my
friend Adam Wade could use some
Bluetooth that's for sure there he is so
uh this is what it is man it's got the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable pill form it gets
delivered right to your doorstep in
discrete packaging you don't have to go
to the doctor to get Bluetooth it's all
online all right and you get your first
month for free try it out and then thank
me later bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg plus they just dropped the new
blue chew mint chewable which has the
same active ingredients as Levitra and
that should have you [ __ ] rocked up
and stocked up bud all right so one more
time bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get your first month for free
free let's get back to the interview uh
give me you guys each give me a new
Young up and coming artist that y'all
are fans of that y'all respect you guys
are actually listening to in your car
when you're riding around if any
um I would say uh
the boy finesse that's two times on some
pimp and [ __ ] he's going crazy his whole
album is about pimping is it I
interviewed him and he's like I'm
bringing the pimp and [ __ ] back well
she's I just gassed he's the [ __ ] he's
spitting his gas Blade him sugar-free
yeah I'd rather give you my [ __ ] during
the interview because he never heard of
sugar-free and his whole his whole album
is about pimping so he's like bro let me
play you something yeah I like him he
carrying himself well he doing a great
job
um I got a couple of cats out of my area
um I like a lot Russell
man I was staying right outside the
crested okay yeah for sure she was
active over there that's 7-Eleven
uh I was I would have to say it's a
bunch of them
you know um Simba killed him with the
freezer you got Simba you got uh you got
uh
who else you got um
you got blast out of uh rich man yo
shout out to Too Short have my favorite
line on the kilo album there's so many
people you're talking about having a
[ __ ] make money off her pee hole oh
yeah I was riding on the Bay Bridge
listening to the pillow album and I was
like that is the most classic
1989 Too Short [ __ ] to say in 2022. come
on but um you know um I got so many
people to say but we gotta like you know
Kendrick is another level of like what
hip-hop should be doing like and he's
like never cease to amaze with his
visuals with his stage performance yeah
and with his songs like he's just
prolific period so he's he's on another
I'm proud of the West Coast for creating
that guy yeah what about YouTube
nobody nobody I like I mean [ __ ] I
respect that I only [ __ ] with
you know when I'm making music I only I
only listen to what I'm making
I respect that yeah I don't want to be
influenced by nobody yeah little babies
and [ __ ] jayco's the [ __ ] there's a
bunch of artists out there I just all I
want to do was just scream and shout
people out because I'm letting them know
I recognize them it's a whole bunch of
people I want to say but I'm I can't be
a money bag money back I can't be
influenced because I'm me 40 and that's
me I'm one of one there's no one on this
planet that stole like a frisbee that
rapping uh calligraphy have you heard
the mount Westmore album I have not
heard it yet so when you listen I mean
I've heard all the like the singles you
know but I haven't heard the album it's
crazy man when you listen to the album
give me your email address when you
listen to the album It's Gonna feel
really good as you listen to it but the
one thing you will notice is that we're
not pandering to the the new sound which
I'm so happy you did not do that I'm not
trying to be something that we're not
and we're we're awesome imagine if I
like if I got the mount Westmore album
and there was like some trapped out 74
BPA I would be disgusting but we're also
not trying to be 1994 either that's fair
we're in there where it's like this I
want to hear these guys sound like this
right now yeah yo between the three
y'all I'm not sure there's an artist
that you guys haven't worked with
obviously you've worked with Pock before
you've worked with Hove biggie I mean we
go on and on I mean Cube [ __ ] I was just
listening to uh the grand finale on the
little John on the east side Boys album
and I was like I forgot Cuba's on this
[ __ ] and I was working out is there for
each of you guys is there a feature that
has not happened yet that just for
whatever reason the planets didn't align
and you didn't you don't have a song
with them yet
um Nas
um
crazy you know rock him I think
everybody and they of MC life want to do
a song with with Rakim at some point
um you know these are the OG's I think I
could do a good song with Buster yeah
him could do a dope song together
um
you know these are the ones that I I
think about uh that I know we could
probably do something crazy for me it
was always uh it's just one answer it
was always like me Missy and Timberland
on the same record I wanted that
is still possible yeah that would have
been the issue what about you 40.
um I would say uh Jay-Z Nas
uh Q-tip
um KRS one who uh Missy
um who else I love to do a song with
Eminem people yeah Trick Daddy
I love Trick Daddy he's he's ready too
yeah and also and like I said I wanted
to just address the m m situation a lot
of his fans thought that I was dissing
him no I could never do that he's one of
the greatest MCS that ever did and got
away with it you understand me do his
job right
but I was dating somebody had asked me
um who would win in a versus battle
between Eminem and Busta Rhymes and I
said Busta Rhyme but versus this because
versus just like animated live
performance yeah that's all I'm saying I
wasn't knocking uh Eminem
got a lot of hits so you know he'll get
the party going live it's crazy like
live bust is like it's like him Tech
Nine and like I don't know that's all
that's all I meant a lot of sweat yeah
that's what I meant I wasn't trying I
didn't I would never dis Eminem he one
of the greats if not I went to a bunch
of show and he called me on stage and
hugged me I'm still mad why you guys a
sweat Hood you just hugged me
his energy his energy is incredible he's
a great guy he just drenched me wrong
with him yeah we had a great verses
right best version it was amazing
definitely the most you were [ __ ]
I was on Mango skydo yo drinking out the
bottle nobody has decided to have fun
like we did nobody it's my brother it
was the funnest doing this with my
brother man
it was the funnest to watch
uh I really really enjoyed their verses
it feels like the versus thing's over
right but did they ever approach you to
do something yeah who was it against or
who were they proposing
I think they was talking ll at one point
they was talking Scarface at one point
um
you said no yeah I said no I said hello
versus is good
but my concept would have been
yo I'm a fan
you do this off I want to enjoy it yeah
like
okay I get to have LL do my favorite LL
songs and he gonna have me do his
favorite Ice Cube song right and it's
not versus but it's it's love it's like
that's the way yo dude yeah do this and
he do rock the bells and he asked me yo
do once upon a time in the projects and
I'll do it you know it's like it that's
that would have been my concept I can't
go against
you know people I admire you know LL is
an OG to me of course in the game uh so
I can't see it me and Scarface you know
um
I know they love each other me and
Scarface love each other but we don't we
don't communicate
enough to do it versus together well
when they when they get there right it
was love I was like oh this is just
gonna be two friends concert for Us
online they had to talk me into it I
wouldn't do it I refused to do it we
talked with Verses first came out yeah
he's like hey man because we talk about
all kind of stuff he's like would you do
it versus
I'm like no I would never do that like
I'm not like and and and and sort of
what cube is saying my catalog is to
it's too sacred to even like put it up
for a debate on like a battle or like
let me battle my catalog and she's like
get out of here man like this right this
is this is like a sacred Indian burial
ground like you can't walk on this you
can't put this up for competition I
could be up there having one of my
favorite MCS talking greasy and [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying just or if you just
had to smash him yeah
cause you got a lot of hits yeah it's
not we agreed on it we agreed on it and
it's gonna be a celebration yeah it's
gonna be a celebration so we just went
up there and had fun we were we wasn't
tripping and that's I just sort of felt
like stupid DMX had a good spirit yeah
yeah but you know I I think it got crazy
you know after that you know three six
one got heavy Too Short e45 my favorite
was Gucci and Jeezy because I know the
Atlanta History that [ __ ] was crazy that
was dope I was just you know had that
butter knife out cutting attention in
the air that was that was thick I think
Jada though was like the MVP of versus
because he kind of like single-handedly
like because he went Saturday showed
everybody like look you got to him
because he understood oh that's another
person I want to do a song with Jadakiss
Jadakiss all these years I want to do a
song with the locks period name my folks
number love respect every time Styles
people we see each other
I respect them all yeah hey what up
y'all we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our folks at
hardean Las Vegas you see them right
there you know I mean shout out to hard
D Man shout out to everybody over there
it's the uh illest dispensary in the
world number one they got the craziest
selection of weed you'll ever go to when
you're in Las Vegas there's only one
place to go that's hard in you pull up
you say hey I heard about this place on
the blue Lakehead podcast and they're
gonna get you hooked up with some
[ __ ] weed all right so go to Jardin
Las Vegas right now if you're in the
city of uh sin or you're going make sure
you uh you know put it put together a
little hour off to the side to make sure
you go get your nice [ __ ] Harding bag
full of uh just a premium weed all right
and not only that you got to shoot them
a follow Harding underscore Las Vegas
I'm gonna shout them out though because
Harding smells the best the dispensary
is just it's not only the best
dispensary in the world it's the best
smelling dispensary in the world and
look now the bootleg kept podcast smells
like Jardin because I have the hardine
signature scent candle you could have
one too you could go to [ __ ] Hardy in
Las Vegas just saying also make sure you
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas that is important you have to
follow them because there's some
[ __ ] accounts out there we
appreciate hard Dean when you're in
Vegas pull up go get you some smoke go
get you some edibles go get you some
[ __ ] carts whatever it is they got it
and they got it at the highest quality
it's the only place I'm smoking from
that's Hardy in Las Vegas let's get back
to the interview
uh Cube uh I saw I saw you talk about
big three and uh kind of Adam Silver's
like lack of support yeah um he need to
go I saw you so I I mean yeah I mean
you're obviously a big NBA fan
historically you've been one of the
biggest Laker fans yes sitting Courtside
all the years yeah
um well I was in my sweet one I wasn't
uh foot on the wood but I was would you
say you were
uh lack of approval of a guy like Adam
Silver has affected you watching the
product as a fan of course you know
understanding the things that they're
doing to prevent the big three from
growing
mainly uh considering our league as
competition which is [ __ ] ridiculous
with three on three we've been around
six years they're five on five they've
been around 76 years right it's no
competition we're complementary and but
labeling us competition prevents other
NBA owners from investing
and if you even think you want to own an
NBA team you won't invest because this
would disqualify you if you invest in a
big three before you bought your NBA
team wow so it eliminates a lot of
potential investors they also are you
know going to to sponsors that they work
with and telling them don't work within
the big three so it's a major issue all
he has to do is with is is not include
the big three in that Clause as as a
competing league and then we can work
with a lot of the same people
um but you know this is a a black owned
League it has
um you know some of the greatest Hall of
Famers that ever played involved in the
league as coaches you know from Dr J to
Rick Barry to also people who are
actively involved in like the NBA
culture who commentated on TV and all
that yeah so these are
you know NBA legends who helped us form
this league NBA family and and for them
to [ __ ] on it like that I think uh is
very disrespectful you know Dr J Iceman
Rick Barry they didn't make a lot of
money in the NBA but the NBA made a lot
of money off them and for them to [ __ ]
on a league that they're involved in
that's three on three uh
to me shows that Adam Silver is out of
touch
he was supposed to bring ice cube and
say I would love to be a part of it and
I want you to be the president of the
journey too we offered the NBA 10 of the
league before we started so we went in
bearing gifts he told told us uh thank
you but no thank you
and then proceeded to [ __ ] with us for
these last six years what's crazy
because it's the competition part is
wild it's like you guys are obviously
uh it's a different time of the year and
it's all it's all players who are known
through the NBA so it just raises brand
awareness for the NBA players that the
NBA have overlooked and you know they
come and get our players and invite I
mean Joe Johnson got signed off of his
run in the big three again they invite
him to the NBA camps we have general
managers coming to the game owners
everybody comes you think David Stern
would have embraced it might have been
worse I don't think so but David Stern
did like what we were doing
but he couldn't get involved because
he's you know ex-commissioner yeah
ex-commissioner with the NBA and Adam
Silver they're just lawyers when it
comes down to it right at the end of the
day they are just lawyers and I think
he's making a big mistake and I think
not uh embracing The Big Three will be
his downfall
let me ask you this because do you think
it could take somebody like
a Steph Curry or like a LeBron
to kind of step in and fully Embrace a
league like that to kind of change
someone like Adam Silver's perspective
on it maybe you know uh LeBron has come
to our games you know he went to the
championship in uh 2019.
um Michael Jordan loves our league [ __ ]
yeah I'm surprised he didn't just say
give me one I'll go one round with y'all
just to show you I don't think you want
to get out there you know I think that's
the past but but for the most part he
loves the league and uh you know people
like Adam told him not to work with us
and so it's just
it's time for this dude to go because
he's showing that he's not really down
with the culture hmm
what are the things you are are going to
try to do to grow The Big Three
um
put a better product on the court
um you know
take care of our sponsors
um
you know be the best Innovative new
league that the world have seen
um and you know uh get a fans what they
pay for you know it's like just just do
better
and you know try to you know get from
under these grips that the NBA has us
under because it is hurting us in more
ways than one yeah
yeah man [ __ ] I I I was telling you it's
an entertaining product for me I'm like
a basketball fanatic so like I'm just
like [ __ ] I could watch uh I don't know
Steven Jackson still player whoever it
is you know like three games of fun
they're fun they are what's the uh OG's
name Who had who changed his name and he
was on the nuggets
who's balling out for y'all changed his
name he remember he was number one on
the Nuggets back in the day and he got
in trouble because he changed his name
to his Muslim name
yeah it's like dope to see him get
Buckets on like way younger dudes
because he had a bad Shake in the NBA
because of that yeah you know what what
people don't realize about the big three
is it's his own game so just because you
got loose in the NBA
and use the [ __ ] in the NBA don't mean
you're gonna come in the big three and
get loose and vice versa just because
people overlooked you in the NBA don't
mean you can't come in the big three and
make an impact and that's what's been
happening you know some dudes think it's
easy but in three on three
you have to have all skills you can't
have no weaknesses you can't be a
specialist can't be a three-point
specialist and and be effective in three
on three hey we gotta stop the interview
to tell you about our family at Odd
Socks that's right the most comfortable
socks in the [ __ ] world go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use that
promo code bootleg and you'll save 20
off Christmas time is it coming and let
me tell you something their Black Friday
sale if you're watching this before
Black Friday you might be watching it
after Black Friday but if Black Friday
hasn't came yet just like Cyrus hasn't
came yet it's been a while he's on a
drought guess what oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg 20 off plus whatever
the [ __ ] else is going on with their
Black Friday sale and let me tell you
they got some new licenses we got to
talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist
and shout out to all you rappers and
people who be pouring your lean into
this [ __ ] some Mountain Dew Baja
Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview you uh spoke recently
about Warner Brothers having the rights
to distribute the Friday Series yeah and
that's obviously your intellectual
property right you came up with that
movie yeah the most impactful movie of
my entire life I was talking like Smokey
from like age eight to twelve my
favorite this is my favorite movie one
of my favorites I know that entire movie
by heart like it's it's bad like I could
recite it when I watch it I watched it
so much as a kid by the way top three
sounds track ever too oh yes don't yeah
one of the best soundtracks ever
um is would you say because you know
you're somebody who's been revolutionary
in so many ways
um is is that a like what lessons did
you learn from the Friday series and not
retaining ownership or not necessarily
being you know in charge of the the
destination of where it goes when you're
doing movies now
is that something that's front of the
mind you know like if you I was part of
the game you know when you do a movie
you have to get it distributed and if
you want your movie to be
um
taking
you know as you know high level
entertainment
uh there's only a few
houses and Studios that can right over
that
um so at the time we didn't have you
know wasn't no streaming Netflix
internet Hulu so we had to assign the
movie the new line
to distribute it and new lines connected
with Warner Brothers so
um you know sometimes when you do one
movie with a company they have the
rights to release the sequels that's
part of the deal and that's the Clause
that we're caught in you know they have
the right to release the sequels and so
the way the stalemate is to not release
you know to do a few and stop and that's
what they did they did three and they
stopped
um and we've been asking them to get the
movie back here's why they won't get a
movie back
Ride Along Straight Out of Compton
new line had both of those movies
they told me both of those movies would
not work on a major scale
we took those movies out of Warner
Brothers took them to Universal
you know so they worked 150 million
dollars from from Ride Along 200 million
from straight out 250 from Straight
Outta Compton so we really embarrassed
embarrassed them so they was like man
you don't really embarrassed us on that
you know I mean like damn uh so we was
like man y'all y'all don't believe in it
so give us the [ __ ] back and they like
we can't give you another movie back
cause I'll get fired you know so it was
on that tip you know they didn't want to
be embarrassed so they didn't want to
let Friday
yeah as a fan I was I always just
assumed Chris Tucker was just not
wanting to do it because because after
the third one it was like okay if they
do a fourth Smokey gotta come back yeah
and obviously rest in peace to John
Witherspoon yeah
um Tiny Lister Tiny Lister passenger
Johnson there's some
very big parts of that universe that
have passed yeah man and that's why I
hate you Warner Brothers because they
they let that happen we could have shot
those movies way before those guys
passed away
um I'll never forgive Toby Emerick and
the guys that was running the show at
the time Faison love because they shot
the face
you know they let guys pass away he was
counting on this movie
yeah and that Universe like fed a lot
like dude I remember you would just go
to like the monster Dub Show and Tiny
Lister would be just there with his bike
yeah taking pics like no I think it was
the most his most recognizable character
of course one of the most recognizable
characters ever he embraced being called
Debo first what like if you say like you
know that's not his name but you I feel
like that's also like a like a people
call you Craig yeah it's like a verb you
could be like yo I deboed him you know
what I mean
ice cube wait who called him Craig my
youngest son he came to the house and my
little my youngest son he's 28 now he's
a little boy he just Craig
Mount Westmore the album uh it comes out
Friday
um I'm very excited this is I'm so glad
you guys put this together I'm so glad
it's actually coming out because I
really I didn't believe it was gonna
happen until y'all did the trailer [ __ ]
and then that song came out and then it
was quiet and I was like ah at least we
got one record you know yeah well
uh now you could like not believe that
the second album is coming out there is
plans to do a second now
is this all happening at the compound at
Snoop spot like were you guys recording
this together we did it all over the
studio so and we might add a few more
new ones to us you know what I mean
because we we and we in that mode it's
easy it's so simple I can tell you
personally you know second album is dope
as [ __ ] it's hard slaps it's hard for us
to make a bad record together I mean you
got it yeah of course so we got to kind
of work hard
to make a bad record did you guys try to
kick the Dr Dre tree to get a beat or
something like one of those millions of
detox songs that he didn't uh doesn't
ever plan on releasing I think I think
Dr Dre is the greatest producer in
hip-hop of all time one of them I think
sometime we can overthink you know you
know when we play dominoes we play we
say steady wrong steady long steady
wrong we need when you take too long to
play your dominoes right
I'm not saying he's steady wrong it's
just he's a perfectionist and I Dre's on
the album he is on here he intros one of
his songs yeah he does well that's all
that matters but we I think we're going
to get a song out of Dre I think he's
just gonna get a few We Love Drake you
know it's the only song well I mean you
know what I was gonna say I forgot about
like
you but I think I in like Peak like 90s
hip-hop like it was was it only natural
born killers that y'all did together
like after NWA happened Natural Born
Killers we did because
chin check chin checks what about the
new NWA hello was a slap hello
yo what's yeah how close were y'all to
doing the [ __ ] new NWA with Snoop was
that like how where are those songs at
not close at all he's like you heard the
songs they came out it is we were about
to get into it and then he he met Eminem
and then he met he met uh 50 and it was
like because chin check was fire yeah he
met he met those two dudes and that just
took his attention all right I mean
listen Andrea is a genius hopefully we
get something out of him well the album
he's been sending me a lot of money he
was an early on Mount Westmore supporter
he got caught wind of the project early
through Snoop he pulled up the Snoop
Studio he put a snapper approve on he
jumped on the song we got a song with
him but it's not it didn't make this out
I'll be on the second album and then um
the Rivalry within the crew uh obviously
[ __ ] the NBA but you know uh Warriors
Lakers right Sports yeah Warriors is new
money 49ers Raiders Lakers is old money
our biggest
arguments yeah Dodgers and Giants and
then the Raiders in 49ers can't agree on
that we don't we're gonna be messing we
only be tripping on Lakers and Warriors
because we know the Warriors is you know
it's just it you know
y'all definitely got um Rings y'all
definitely do yeah yeah so like we just
it's Jimmy G's out [ __ ] y'all are done
you think we're done I mean you guys are
making the Super Bowl we got you don't
think it's gonna win you just gotta let
let the chicken he's gonna win the game
New Year's Day Raiders play the 49ers in
Vegas
who you putting your money on
if the water's in the building the 49ers
are going no Jimmy G who you putting
money on I don't know about that Purdy
are they going to sign Baker Mayfield I
don't know we're going to see it what if
you don't know about Purdy y'all
wouldn't pick somebody up from there yes
we did Josh we got in here we got Josh
yeah yeah we got him too we good we're
we're not worried about anything we are
running game ain't no need to explain
because we got running games
defense wins games ain't no need to
explain we got running games on the
table man it's going it's bleeding
through the microphone are you are you a
Raider fan Cube yeah come on now well I
mean this is Ice Cube the president of
Raider Nation
the Raiders can go one the Raiders could
go one and sixteen through the whole
year you understand me through the whole
year have you guys been doing this have
you guys been to a Rams game in
elementary
I need you to hear me on this I'm
supposed to go Thursday I need you to
hear this I need you to hear this yeah I
need you to hear this okay the Raiders
look I I don't hate the Raiders this is
the fans I don't hate the fans it's a
certain it's LA radio I know I love this
is the LA radio which they you're trying
to sell some records let me talk let me
talk they've supported me more just as
much as the Bay Area if not so it's not
about that it's nothing there's nothing
against y'all there's nothing you're
wearing silver and black man
why are you wearing sports why are you
talking over me because this guy's
always talking his [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
Cardinal fan he's a Niner fan we're in
the same division
don't say it let me just let me say this
the Raider fans okay it could be they
could be the Raiders the Raiders do
great I like they they be they be
Brewing they own quarterback car I'm
like why are you building why are you
doing the Beloved car you see they get
upset Jimmy G y'all love him we love
them
picks for [ __ ] trailers
that's why we're gonna win this whole
thing but listen let me say this this is
this this is the common denominator of
my whole thing from just the whole
reason I got on the microphone okay go
ahead get it out the Raider fans look
the Raiders could be one and the Raiders
could be one and 16 you draw stop
drinking my wine 116. you're ready to go
1-16 and be like Raider Nation
116 bro like they won the [ __ ] Super
Bowl it's all good man hey look most
overrated dynasty of all time the
Warriors appreciate you guys coming
who's your team who's your team don't
worry about me oh yeah stop it man
more yay go run that [ __ ] up hey go back
hey I love y'all la I love y'all thank
you for everything